[Music]
i
knew it i knew it
damn it feels good to be right oh
oh oh i uncovered a scam
unintentionally that's right for those
who don't know
the other day i did a video where i
tried out
a 20 whiskey or a seven hundred dollar
whiskey and i never tried the 700
once before and i you know i pride
myself in my whiskey tasting i don't
drink anymore
but i still know a good whiskey if a
whiskey's been aged
23 years i know i'm able to identify it
now even though it was super
embarrassing i preferred
the 20 whiskey
yeah that's the bushido much richer
flavor
they have to taste hits way more first
when they hit your tongue it's not that
much difference
but the flavor develops differently did
i get it right
no did i got it wrong no [ __ ] way i
went on this whole [ __ ] preach
are you serious i didn't mean that i
just seemed like these and then
that was checked but they said more look
out
yeah this is the jameson
are you kidding me 20 pound whiskey
i i decided you know what this is
embarrassing
i'm ashamed but that was my opinion i
should post it anyway
even if people laugh at me well turns
out i was right
this seven hundred dollar whiskey is not
real whiskey
they literally just age it in a barrel
it's chochu or whatever
shorshu it's not real whiskey it's 80
uh liquor that they rebranded in america
and they upped the price they put a
bunch of samurai [ __ ] on it
they're like oh bushy though oh now it
not it's 23 years
it's insane i can't believe we uncovered
this so apparently this is quite common
it's not illegal to do what they're
doing because we clearly need like
stricter restriction on what is
qualified as a whiskey
but do not i repeat do not spend 700
on that because that is not what it's
worth and it's not what it tastes like
because jameson tasted better
and i'm so glad this had a wholesome
nice ending that's a reddit moment
anyway
let's get into the why leave your memes
on
just wanted to say thank you to the
subreddit we did it boys
man bun man is back how many layers is
this gonna go is it
just gonna keep going well
thank you it's wholesome and i like it
keep it going
marseille's taking control of her pierce
no
she's been feeding me pasta that's
illegal
i know it i i haven't done it so far
have i
no did it work yes yes it did work
but that's what cost wow that's a sick
fan art though
honestly that's a really good fan art
some watercolor
nice dude i know i mean nice girl my mom
at the airport oh hey
isn't that the youtuber guy you watch
all the time me oh my god yes it's him
mom why don't you go and ask him for a
selfie me
i'll be back tears no
no mom mom what but why not
because good soldiers follows orders
that's a wholesome reddit moment thank
you guys respect
pewds fan art how many will simp for me
damn well that's a good
that's a legit good fanner that gets an
upload and i'll simp for you dude
look at this meme edgar yes beards can i
sleep
can i sleep now
so cute the picture used at your funeral
may
have already been taken oh god that's so
neat
that's a weird thought no don't let it
be that one
there should be a there should be a
website that lets you pick right if i
die
what photo do i want i don't know just
pick one that makes me look handsome i
don't care
no this one i'm joking don't you
don't don't don't i'm serious though
time travel gets invented
girls oh my god i'm gonna eat my younger
self boys
don't take that picture felix stop it
felix
dammit arnold where were you where were
you
you're a big guy wherever you are now
when pierce likes your meme oh my god
oh my god what is that i just got big pp
status mom
i just got it yes we're all going to die
yes there it is my culture is a scam
well it's not it's is it i don't know if
you can call it a scam
it's just it's tricking tricking people
yeah don't sue me i'm not calling it a
scam don't sue me but
it's disingenuous
[Music]
that's so weird
you know what that was beautiful thank
you very much i'm not the girl this will
be ignored well i saw it
okay and i simper guys too no
discrimination
god of pee pee damn who's that head
what the hell i like the outfit i like
the tambourine
and i smack at the top of the puppet
that's dope i see nieza very big peepee
huge
[Laughter]
six non-sims and one secret simp side
editing in a picture of himself when
pewds said simp to make the video better
that's respect that's respect honestly
that's a that's pretty non-simpable move
maybe cybe not simp after all but if
seif not sim
and i'm not simp that means
oh my god
[Music]
dude i understand the nihongo so the
subtitles
are not even correct cringe big thanks
to patreons all right we're doing
patreon shout outs here
that's dope though you deserve it spin
apples
that's so good oh my god the upvotes
you're gonna get
lmao watching the new pewts video oh
it's the one where
you had to see who was gay i think the
man in the headphones is the gay one
grandma grandma you say that to my face
grandma
not that there's anything wrong grandma
i'll be gay for grandma
[Music]
oh my gosh
that was amazing tallmec kotovsky
if i were a girl it takes a lot of
courage to do this
that's big pippy that's huge courage if
you see it don't ruin it for others
i mean i i don't see anything what are
you talking about it's about goddamn
time
i'm done stop it oh god it's still oh
god oh no
i can't ah what has happened there it is
thank you thank you thank you
oh oh god stop it
don't do martial like this
[Applause]
[Music]
you make me muhammad happy thank you
whoa whoa that's some trippy [ __ ] dude
oh my god i didn't know i could do that
that's insane
that's big peepee two-year-olds be like
two-year-olds uh cyber remembering the
past after marrying bilderfin
they called me a symph but
little do they know i [ __ ] up guys
damn imagine a cute girl holding it damn
can you imagine the uploads if a cute
girl held it
that's big peepee i respect it i'm
imagining marcia holding it
because she's the cutest girl oh
that's really the love that huge peepee
felix should do a lawyer where he only
speaks swedish
and there are english subtitles sorry
scythe if he actually decides to do it
cyber if this ever happens
commandos
yeah that's all you gotta do man that's
all you gotta do
yeah someone did it no way i asked my
figurine
because uh you can change the attachment
for it uh they're still available by the
way pewdiepie.store if you want one
so you can change the yeah let's stop
[Music]
ah it's nice quality where my head guys
oh there you go so cute thank you
no one pukes when he likes a meme
biggest
stickers largest pipish
same energy
jax fan art feuds fan art damn that's a
really good one i'm jack though
legit bestie you look so good in real
life oh my god
love your face we look ugly even in real
life bro
but nice peepee bro you got a nice dick
though
yeah there's nothing more straight than
being gay everyone knows this
let's put on the headphones god damn it
there we go that's better i don't drink
whiskey anymore
the company that sent him a bottle of
whiskey that costs
600 pounds no it doesn't it costs 80
pounds we just still you know something
but
i'm so confused why i got such good
rating that's what really threw me off
look here we go on this website 800.
but on this on this website it's rated
9.2
perfect wiki perfect wiki
alex your rating what do i think
i think you could literally just buy
jameson
and have a better time and save yourself
eight hundred dollars
finally managed to beat pewdiepie timber
simulator it's still relevant god damn
it
oh god if i lose a tuber simulator does
that mean that
i am not relevant no
i'm relevant i'm also relevant
all right man you gotta respect man's
drip though
god damn god damn he looks good anyone
else remember this pick a perch
yeah classic time travel invented girl
i'm gonna meet my younger self
boys hey man keep making hot dogs
it would all work out for you man you
get one
tambourine tam you get one bin
tap
ksi joint floor again question mark epic
yo ksi how's your flute playing skills
get a flute and let's create a band dude
i know you do music and [ __ ] let's get
it
pewdiepie i don't like this meme small
peepee people who live in greece
uh where having a tiny penis is a sign
of intelligence
oh you mean ancient greece what the [ __ ]
jokes from you i'm into that [ __ ]
okay all right whatever helps you cope
my dude
whatever helps you cope dude most
popular youtuber pewdiepie just donated
a hundred thousand to
el japanese lebanese red cross correct
uh the money has been transferred
and it's thanks to you guys for being
members all the member
revenue goes to charity so i appreciate
it there it is
damn that looks cool 3d printed guru
logan glasses
and tambourine requested
i gotta get a 3d printer that looks
[ __ ] though picture of me
a cute anime girl
thank you for specifying should i hire a
girl to hold it
you know it would work that's a youtube
video right there
[Music]
no looks like
i don't want to take pictures with fans
understand we'll have a great day thanks
for understanding
can i take a video then
[Music]
no die i thought i killed you get out of
my sight
society gamers are fat and lazy
whoa look how strong whoa whoa
bro i need more bites i need to bulk
more but i don't want to be
fat bro but like come on oh what
20 muscle increase let's get it
you see someone using fahrenheit
download them we did it boys fahrenheit
no
more thank you fahrenheit thank you
fahrenheit gang
celsius gang for life i made a pewdiepie
injured with timber simulator
[Music]
wow
the most relevant game diver's emulator
whoa that's so cool
oh they gave maya and i she doesn't have
one
oh head guy
it's so cute kurt's creations thank you
very much
that's so cute hey another great fan art
god damn it all right what do we have
side
all right let's zoom in all right what
do we got what do we got
what do we got huh
what do we got whoa that is weird oh
that is really weird
fan art of felix dad holding fan out of
marzia holding fan out of maya holding
for another edgar
holy [ __ ]
persona 5 cocomelon intro
[Applause]
persona hey
hey
whoa i like that that's huge creepy
dope dope i like it
does this work i mean hell yeah oh look
how cute edgar is
wait what the [ __ ] is this my friend has
posted the first half of the image
my friend posted the other goddamn what
the hell is this
no don't don't don't do it
don't do it don't do it please are you
gay
no understandable have a great day very
epic
pewdiepie's new video in a nutshell yeah
that's pretty much it
petition to get mr beast to set up an
event like team trees to pull
40 million piece of plastic yeah this is
really important stuff
that's great i'm happy to support that
no this meme is dying i don't want to
die
don't worry girl we'll always be
together even if we die
we're going to die bro we're ahead of
you bro
what even this is me with this boy
martial close your eyes
i am the producer i make the video
pasta noises okay i close no that was
not a simp moment i just randomly felt
like doing it
i randomly wanted to do it i'm not as
i'm noticing i'm yourself
i'm not i'm not say this
i have not been blaming cyber being a
simp to deflect people from calling me
yourself
no time don't do it you'll become a
champ i mean hi
hi sip say hi
you said hi to a girl bro she
is that from the doc stream that was so
funny we spent uh
20 minutes trying to figure out how to
add each other it was a epic highlight
you will never escape my hugs
[Laughter]
[Music]
doodle guy huge dick
you will never escape in the hug
looks like a depressed 40 year old
father who just lost his job yeah
that's pretty much what he is anyway uh
uh uh
oh
well the pot thickens eh guess
ooh jack all right all the simp jokes
aside
side we have made merch that is just
for you that's right we have the simp
t-shirt
that stands for squirrels in my
underpants so if you're not a simp
but a synth get this merged to prove it
s-i-m-p
squirrels in my pants it's made out 100
combed ring split cotton it's very which
means it's very comfortable
buy a hundred thousand now and that's it
for even up
holy bro see mon hey dog
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big tv
pre-order promotion i mean